pablo ortega pagó 11 mil dólares por un
viaje exclusivo unos contrabandistas lo
llevarían de méxico a eeuu le prometían
garantías y comodidades para un
recorrido que acabó con la muerte por
asfixia de ortega y decenas de migrantes
más iba a pasar un carro con ellos
indirecta 20 años para allá
así sin complicaciones y nada
de que se les atravesara algo en el
camino que todo iba a ser directo le
aseguraban cervezas de cortesía
videojuegos e incluso un cómodo lugar de
descanso y afirmaban que llegaría sin
problemas a florida eeuu para
encontrarse con su madre pero el cuerpo
de pablo fue encontrado en san antonio
texas al lado de 52 más en un remolque
de un camión sin agua ni aire
acondicionado
después de arduos trámites para la
repatriación de su cuerpo sus familiares
reunidos en mexico le dan un último
adiós pues a la vez me da me da mucha
felicidad porque él está aquí me da
tristeza porque pues ya no podemos estar
compartiendo dichas cosas que pues igual
entre todos los amigos siempre
compartíamos
si es algo triste su caso hace parte de
un fenómeno cada vez más frecuente a
medida en que se acrecientan los
controles fronterizos para entrar a eeuu
una situación de la que se aprovecha la
industria de contrabando de personas que
generan miles de millones de dólares
pero representa un gran peligro según la
onu los fallecimientos fronterizos
relacionados con vehículos y transporte
crecieron más que cualquier otra causa
de muerte entre 2020 y 2021